from the post millennial Arizona
superintendent sued over a sex chat room
for minors the lawsuit alleges Hoffman
advertised links to chat rooms where
miners discuss sex and gender with
adults present and without parents
necessarily knowing this according to AZ
free news the lawsuit filed in the
Maricopa County superior court alleges
Hoffman advertised links so we read that
judge Peter Thompson Will preside the
chat rooms have have Quick Escape
functions that Hoffman claims violate
Arizona's parents Bill of Rights in the
suit it specifies how hoppin advertised
Q chat space which is aimed at lgbtq
youth 13 years and older
chat rooms include sex and relationships
q a four trans non-binary youth activism
allyship four trans non-binary youth sex
ed
yeah so these schools are having these
conversations with your kids and they're
encouraging them to speak this is the
crazy thing it's not the first time
we've heard this where they bring minors
into rooms with adults without the
parents knowing knowing like come on man
because it's amazing to me it wasn't
that long ago that I mean like hey you
know I would I would see a student at
Walmart and it was weird for them you
know I mean it's like you have kids and
a wife and I'm like yeah but you know I
mean you're in the classroom you're
teaching academics you're going through
the stand I mean and to them it's like a
Bizarro world to see you like in real
life you know we've gone from that to
hey we're going to bring in minors we're
going to talk about sex and we're going
to talk about your sexual orientation
we're going to talk about your your
gender it's outrageous it's amazing how
quickly we've gone from that type of
perspective to just full-on
indoctrination and it's not just schools
it's parades it's public showings it's
TV shows it's movie series it's social
media where of course it's promoted in
the algorithm and the people and young
kids especially are gaslit that this is
okay and they get special brownie points
on the internet they get more likes they
get more we're playing the algorithm if
they declare that they're a part of the
larger accepted group that of course
everyone wants them to be which is
absolutely crazy I just learned about
the the transition rooms that you were
telling me I just looked it up that also
is kind of mind-boggling to see these
type of things going on at school
without the participation of the parents
and this is why I think homeschooling
has been on such a huge rise and I think
if there's a caveat to any of this it's
that people are finally learning because
of covid because the last two years
because of all the zoom calls they're
finally seeing all the horrendous things
that their kids are being indoctrinated
to that they're saying enough is enough
we're taking the kids from school we're
teaching them the important things that
they actually will use in life and and
changing the game this way there's
millions of people homeschooling and I
think this is a a sign that I think is
is a positive and a good I got to make
this point though as an app developer
myself you know having the Quick Escape
function is when you have a really good
honest app you always have to have
something so you can Tetris quickly exit
out of it so you don't get caught
speaking to a child I mean just the fact
that they're speaking I mean seriously
they're like oh we got to have a
function Quick Escape functionality in
case somebody walks in the room I mean
that's sick that's perverted and that's
it goes to and the reason why I thought
about that is when you talked about the
transition Clauses it's like you know
you have to talk about this with a
developer like oh we we may need to be
able to get out of this instantly
because we could be talking about
something that's very demonic or evil so
it just that just shows you how much how
many layers are inappropriate and how
illegal yeah of course yeah so you know
that that website should not exist and
that's a teacher doing it so well so
what what's uh what's going on with the
uh with you and say school choice or
homeschooling or micro schooling right
you know I I couldn't agree more that
what we've seen is a parent should have
opened their eyes through covid seeing
what's going on in the classrooms to say
we want more school choice we want more
options for our kids hey if a parent
wants to homeschool kid or send them to
a private school and these micro schools
I'm glad you brought that up we are
seeing incredible Innovation that's
going on because hey a parent a couple
of teachers go hey we we can we can do
project-based learning we can have kids
develop their own company I mean we can
we can have you do create a startup here
you go here here are some materials you
guys started up and we'll we'll help
work through all that we can do math
science through this type of innovation
and it's really unlocking the potential
and again
this whole one-size-fits-all model in
education has to stop we all know that
like you know not everybody takes the
traditional path to be successful in
life and we push kids in it and when we
make them feel like failures when they
don't go down that road this is why I
thought school was just miserable
because like for me
that we would spend one whole week on a
sub subject that I would learn in 10
minutes they'd open the book and be like
here's this you know current lesson
today and at the end of the week you
take a test so like on day one I read it
I'm like I get it yeah I'm good and then
I'm sitting there and they punish me for
it they say you're being bad you're not
paying attention you're in trouble you
get attention public school's a scam I
mean it's it's an indoctrination Center
that was literally created on the
foundations of the Rockefeller family
that wanted good slave workers that were
going to be good obedient workers in the
factory everything is based on that old
principle Society doesn't run this way
anymore we don't have any factories the
Rockefellers along with Henry Kissinger
and and Nixon sent them over to China
when they opened up China to the rest of
the world but but but this is again a
failed system that is failing our
country our IQs have been going down
dramatically intelligence and and
emotional health has been going down
dramatically and I think this is done
deliberately and I think this is a
success of the system rather than a
failure because when you truly look at
how the system and why the system was
started it's starts to make a lot more
sense that's exactly right I mean that's
where understanding that it was
developed in the industrial revolution
to say we want to have good Factory
workers and what did we want we wanted
first of all to make sure they could go
tend the crops which is why we had
Summers off so that they could tend
Harvest that's literally the reason for
the schedule and we still have the I
mean lunch breaks specifically so
regurgitate repeat follow orders follow
the procedures punch the hole exactly
where we tell you to punch the hole in
and
was designed in order to do and now we
live in this incredibly agile
economy where literally the thing that
is most productive is the ability to be
uh you know
be creative uh be Innovative
um you know be able to create on your
own and think outside the box and think
about things differently and literally
have a system in place that does not
help that flourish doesn't build upon
that as a premise and so that's what
we've got to continue to do is to push
for an education system that unlocks the
potential of every learner and that
means it's different that means it's
different for every learner and to your
point
if you have a learner that can take off
let them take off why are we slowing
them down and why are we allowing
ourselves to overly regulate and push a
model on kids that frankly like I said
you can talk to people every day they
don't follow the traditional path to be
successful hey College guess what a lot
of people don't want to send their kids
to college that's not even the
traditional way to be successful never
has been it's a myth moderate a relative
I think that only emerged with the
millennial generation for the most part
gen xers probably to a certain degree
more so and mostly Millennials I don't I
I think maybe look at the data because
for me it's just what I what I
understand about the narratives they
give us all the time is that you know
the greatest Generation had high school
diplomas and fed their families and the
Boomers didn't go to college some of
them did many of them did but most or a
large amount didn't and they were still
able to work jobs and be successful such
a you know 60 of okolonians don't go to
college and we look at the jobs you know
Walmart right now is running this on a
loop they've got their commercial of
they are starting semi truck drivers at
six figures wow you can go here for for
six weeks you get a CDO license you can
get behind a truck and you start 120 000
dollars
there are kids I get to travel around
the country I get this kind of training
I get I get anabolic benefits are great
too but you start looking through this
and go College this whole all kids
should go to college it's been a myth
and to your point it's never actually
been true the majority of people never
have gone to college so again doctors
lawyers sure go to college but the
reality is we have pushed kids down a
path for so long and said this was what
success looks like and by the way if you
don't do that you're not a success and
then you wonder why kids a lot of kids
hate school then you wonder why by the
way teachers get frustrated in that
environment there's a meme where it's a
woman looking at her kid and as a
garbage man and she's like it's a
political cartoon she's like you better
go to college otherwise you're going to
end up like him and then the guy's like
I make six figures and have health care
benefits like like you're ragging on the
garbage guy garbage man and he's getting
paid way better than all these college
grads it's it's crazy to think and and
also it's just another problem with that
it's a liberal Elite mentality and a lot
of neocon conservative types have this
too the Suburban families that like
there's demeaning work that like you
don't want to do that job that's a bad
job why would you want it's like these
are very important jobs that people got
to do and it's like you should be
eternally grateful someone's willing to
handle your bag of crap and take it out
of your house could you imagine these
people would be crying in two seconds if
the if the if the sanitation workers
were just like you know what take your
own trash now you can be that person and
they're gonna be like please please
there's feces yeah they'll beg they'll
beg and cry it's so elitist and
condescending too because you know we
looked at this you know I know I
remember which thing Tinker was but they
did kind of a study on happiness you
know what who who says their most
fulfilled by their job I don't know if
you if you guys remember saying I think
it was AI but it was a one of the
highest rated ones was a custodian at a
school
and the reason why was because the
custodian felt and saw kids that were
excited to go play on the playground
they were excited to be at school and he
realized and again that group realized
what I'm doing every day is helping make
kids happy and these teachers are
thankful they come to me and tell me
thanks and again that's a job that you
would think hey you know cleaning up a
school every day they rated it as one of
the most yeah one of the happiest uh you
know occupations because they said look
we see what we're doing as a fulfillment
to society and that's a reality though
but the liberal Elites think that a PhD
and you know underwater basket weaving
or some are you know humanity is the
end-all be-all even if you don't have a
job even if there's not a job on it they
think that means success rather than
contributing to society who was it on
The View who thought that uh Joe's that
Jill Biden was a doctor Sonny Austin
think was it I think she was his wife
she's a Jill is a good doctor she's a
good doctor and they're like she's
actually not a doctor she's not she has
an education doctorate or whatever close
enough I would let her do surgery on me
but hey I want to make a point I
couldn't get in I couldn't get in on the
education thing and I want to say you
know I thought the Rockefellers did a
good job uh you know creating a
curriculum of uh good workers and I
think it did a good job but for me when
Barack Obama's husband got rid of the
square pizza Michelle that is when I
lost all my love for uh public schooling
because once once they took away the
good food oh I remember those pizzas I
actually like and Michelle Obama got rid
of him trying to make everybody go vegan
Michelle let us eat some cheese pizza I
know you guys love cheese pizza
yeah we used to we used to have those
you know those squares and it was like
the cheese who knows what it was we had
blue hot dogs that was the weird wait
why were they blue with the Gatorade I
wouldn't need them they were gray so
they were they were like if you'd walk
in and there was like hot dogs in the
like I think they were boiling them and
then they'd like they put them like the
craziest thing about school food is that
never made sense they'd give you a hot
dog with no bun because it was just like
whatever they had but we would very
often hot dogs would be gray and then
sometimes they would be blue blueish
gray and I just I wouldn't still
healthier than the vegan diet but that's
the second point to make here thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the Tim cast iron podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there